ok pensemos en un par de palabras sal y
sodio muchas veces las dicen de manera
indiferente sin embargo tomaremos unos
minutos para saber realmente cuál es la
diferencia
cuando hablamos de sal yo me imagino el
salero que está en la mesa de del
comedor y que normalmente me gusta
utilizar a la hora de la comida o la
cena sin embargo estoy comiendo lo
suficiente o mucho ahora veremos si tomo
una cucharadita de estas que se utilizan
para el café y la llenará con sal se
vería algo así mi cucharadita llena y la
pesará en una báscula esto tendría un
peso alrededor de 6 gramos que también
se puede leer como 6 mil miligramos
miligramos
esto es mucho o es poco a nivel químico
realmente la sal es cloruro de sodio
donde enea es sodio
es cloruro
aportemos lo aquí
existe nivel químico un peso que tiene
cada uno de los átomos y esto nos ayuda
para saber qué elemento es más pesado y
alinearlos tal vez del más ligero al más
pesado investigando en la tabla
periódica el sodio tienen 23 unidades de
masa atómica mientras que el cloruro
tiene un peso de 35 unidades de masa
atómica si sumamos ambos elementos
tendremos un total de 58 unidades de
masa atómica totales para el cloruro de
sodio es decir para nuestra sal
recordemos que una es unidades
de masa atómica
qué porcentaje de esta sal de este
cloruro de sodio es sodio y qué
porcentaje es cloruro para saberlo
haremos la siguiente división 23
unidades de masa atómica
correspondientes al sodio las
dividiremos entre 58 unidades de masa
atómica correspondientes al total del
cloruro de sodio
y esto nos da un total de 40 por ciento
haremos lo mismo con el cloruro 35
unidades de masa atómica entre 58
unidades totales
el cloruro de sodio y esto nos da el
otro 60% restante
significa que de nuestra sal el 40 por
ciento es únicamente sodio y 60 por
ciento es cloruro considerando que no
hubo bichitos que se metieran al salero
ok de estos 6.000 miligramos
vamos a sacar la proporción que hemos
calculado
veamos 40% por 6000 miligramos y 60% de
los 6000 miligramos estamos sacando la
proporción en nuestra cucharadita
esto significa 40 por ciento de 6.000
son 2400 miligramos
absolutamente de sodio y lo mismo bajo
60 por 6000 son 3 mil 600 miligramos
absolutos de cloruro de sodio en esta
cucharadita de 6 mil miligramos
consideremos dos tipos de dieta diaria
que pueden recomendar los nutriólogos
una de ellas es una dieta regular en el
caso de que tenga un estatus de salud
agradable y puede hacer ejercicio y mi
edad y todo esté bien o una dieta baja
en sodio vamos a hacer una tabla en el
que pongamos los miligramos y a cuánto
corresponde esta sal una dieta regular
para mí tendría la recomendación de
alrededor de 2.300 miligramos de sodio o
1.500 miligramos de sodio si se dan
cuenta estos 2300 son muy similares a
2400 yo realmente no tendría mayor
conflicto
estamos hablando de aproximados si lo
medimos en la cucharadita que hablábamos
hace un momento tendremos la siguiente
forma gráfica de medirlo
en una dieta regular de 2 mil 300
miligramos yo pudiera comerme hasta una
cucharada completa justo como la que
pesamos de sal al día
y si estuviera en una dieta baja en
sodio sólo dos terceras partes ya que
son los recomendados por mi nutriólogo y
hasta ahí pudiera comer de sodio durante
el día